ce qu'on observe ici c'est la mise en
place de nouveaux filtres ou de
nouvelles barrières pour protéger
l'espace public français pour pu
protéger les institutions ou les
industries françaises de l'information
qui vient de l'étranger d'une
information qui estime et toxiques ou ou
le civ
c'est sans aucun doute une étape
supplémentaire dans la guerre de
l'information mondialisée entre grandes
puissances et c'est une avancée dans la
volonté française de retrouver ses
prérogatives régaliennes dans le domaine
de l'information puisque comme je vous
le disais c'est une manière de recréer
des filtres ou créer des frontières dans
l'espace public national
à une époque où les flux d'informations
sont mondialisés mais il ya de ce point
de vue une chose importante je crois à
noter à savoir que cette volonté de
d'établir des filtres ou de rétablir les
frontières c'est pas quelque chose de
fondamentalement nouveau à l'époque des
télévisions transnet départ dans des
radios transnationales ou plus récemment
à l'époque des télévisions
transnationales les états la france
comme d'autres pays a mis en place des
dispositifs assez efficace pour contrer
l'information qui vient de l'étranger
il y avait si vous voulez par exemple
cet effort qui avait été fait par la
france dans les années 2000 ont pour
interdire la télévision du hezbollah
libanais al manar en france parce
qu'elle diffusait des des émissions à
contenu antisémite et l'idée à l'époque
était de couper le flux de la télévision
de la télédiffusion satellitaire d'al
manar voyez en fait si c'est politique
de protection de l'espace public
national par rapport à l'information qui
vient de l'étranger à la une grande
postérité est donc là en fait que l'on
observe c'est on peut interpréter ce
dispositif comme une manière de mettre
en place de progresser dans la guerre de
l'information à
l'époque des réseaux numériques